Hello. Hiya. What's your name?
My name is Yas Hansford.
What's your favorite TV show?
Oh, I think I'd have to say Gilmore Girls,
just because I relate to the character so much.
And I love Laura and I so much.
Her sense of humor is incredibly funny.
Fair enough.
What's your, um,
plan for the future?
I don't know.
I'm not really sure what I want to do when I'm older.
I don't have any set career plans,
but I think there's a lot of things I'm interested in.
Past politics,
I have something to do with science.
I really enjoy science lesson and especially maths.
And I love talking to people.
So definitely a people job. Yeah.
What's your, um,
campaign about?
So I have three campaigns.
My first one is about youth engagement
and making sure that young people have opportunities,
because that's such an important thing.